bonjour eric zemmour bonjour on a bien
vu avec les municipales aujourd'hui ce
sont les verts qui sont la force motrice
de la gauche commence est venue possible
t il ont incontestablement gagné les
municipales leur victoire dans les
grandes métropoles bordeaux lyon
strasbourg et même dans des villes
moyennes comme besançon et puis même
leur défaite de justesse à lille contre
martine aubry à toulouse contre jean luc
moudenc en fut incontestablement les
grands vainqueurs de l'élection
même si on peut toujours limité bien sûr
un pour deux raisons d'une part les
normes abstentions et deuxièmement le
fait qu' il ne gagne que dans les
métropoles c'est une france des
métropoles c'est la france qui a donné
emmanuel macron 2017 selon vous les
écologistes sont en quelque sorte des
agrégateurs de différentes minorités
expliquez-nous il gagne dans le cadre
d'aidé des listes d'union de la gauche
comme avant sauf que eux qu était la
troisième roue du carrosse ils sont
devenus les patrons ils tiennent les
rênes aujourd'hui dans toutes ces villes
voyez c'est le seul changement sur 30
ans on a basculé le ps à remplacer le pc
dans les années 70 et 80
aujourd'hui les verts en place le paient
comme patron du numéro de mai mais la
logique est toujours la même ouais ça
c'est une première chose deuxièmement
qu'est ce que c'est que les pères c'est
d'abord des pastèques c'est à dire des
gens qui sont à l'extérieur d'air et à
l'intérieur rouges et parfois rouge vif
depuis des années ils ont agrégé toutes
les minorités qui font la loi dans la
rue dans les médias ils ont avec ils ont
tables ouvertes chez les verts il y a
les féministes les antiracistes les
racialiste les des coloniaux les
islamistes tout ce petit monde
et tout à fait à l'aise chez lui chez
les verts en vérité les verts sont la
mise en oeuvre de la fameuse théorie de
terra nova vous souvenez ya quelques
années terra nova qui avait conseillé au
parti socialiste d'abandonner
l'électorat populaire français les plus
ouvriers les employés qu'ils soient sont
passés au rassemblement national soit ne
vote pas pour une grande alliance entre
les bobos des centres villes les jeunes
femmes éduquées voyez avec des diplômes
et la jeunesse de l'immigration tout ce
petit monde là mais le le ps est encore
trop trop handicapés par des conceptions
que j'allais dire archaïque c'est à dire
républicaine laïque patriotes ils y
voyaient bruit c'était plus grand chose
mais il y en avait encore encore
trompant faisons là et les verts eux ils
sont mondialistes multiculturaliste sans
scrupules et voyez sens sans vergogne
est ce qu'après un score pareil aux
municipales les écologistes peuvent
avoir toutes les espérances pour les
présidentielles c'est pas assez patient
c'est possible mais c'est pas sûr il va
y avoir deux obstacles le d'après moi le
premier c'est que
tout le monde va être écologiste a
commencé le lendemain des municipales il
a repris l'essentiel des propositions de
là commence aux citoyennes mélenchon dit
qui l'écologie depuis des années les
socialistes ont aussi qu logist les tout
le monde et écologistes même la droite
commence à dire que elle doit être
écologique etc et le rassemblement
national fait l'éloge des circuits
courts
voilà tout le monde et écologique donc
il n'est pas sûr que les gens préfèrent
l'original à la copie surtout quand on
j'espère qu'on arrivera à leur démontrer
que sont plus d'extrême gauche que
d'écologistes et deuxièmement les verts
des tests l'élection présidentielle pour
deux raisons l'élection présidentielle
d'abord c'est la monarchie républicaine
qui vomissent
pour eux c'est du fascisme et
deuxièmement les vers se moque
complètement de la nation sont des vrais
internationaliste des vrais mondialistes
ils veulent sauver la planète mais mais
le sort de la nation française leur
importe peu
or l'élection présidentielle c'est quand
même ça reste quand même c'est pourquoi
la volonté du général de gaulle
l'élection qui décide du sort de la
nation merci eric zemmour